wo ist das geil hatte lief
[Musik]
neun leute und willkommen bei einer
neuen folge happy meals ich habe mal
wieder so richtig bock dieser spiel
endlich zu zocken ich war ja jetzt eine
zeitlang im urlaub in hamburg und danach
noch auf sylt und ihr fragt euch mit
sicherheit jetzt in den kommenden
minecraft zu get up warum wir denn da
teilweise themen besprechen die schon
etwas älter sind und so weiter wir haben
einfach schon 20 folge im voraus
aufgenommen also das sind den von
topshop media kilian und bäumen und ich
waren das als vivant vier leute und wir
haben uns echt so oft einen abgesackt
und haben dann einfach gesagt kommt
machen wir noch eine folge und neun
erfolg und noch eine folge lang wollten
wir stoppen dann noch eine folge gemacht
also das war echt extrem geil aber ich
will gar nicht die lange hier um heißen
brei quatschen ihr habt mit einer menge
levels gemacht obwohl ich das noch
einmal kurz erwähnt habe finde ich auf
jeden fall sehr geil
vor allem dieses level von crafter das
glied na ja also wir werden erstmal ein
bisschen durchzocken von gameplay das
war mein erstes level viel spaß so sein
erstes level
ich weiß nicht ob das dann unbedingt
ganz gut sein wird wir nehmen wahr denn
es könnte ein wenig ruckeln weil ich
gerade den bei einer hochland gameplay
das ist mein erstes level und ich hoffe
die alle mit den ersten levels elster
unglaublich so nehmen wir diesen typen
high court crafter das ist mein erstes
level und ich hoffe es gefällt ihr
da haben jetzt mal gucken so weit man
dass der sohn und da bin ich dass der
sohn
ok ich hab' ich gerade ein wenig angst
daher zu fahren und ich fahre mal kurz
fiel aber man sieht dass der erste level
is tschuldigung aber wir können nicht
ganz menschen hier bringt das doch da
hast du natürlich wäre wenn er dann so
alle aufeinander verbandsboss ab in den
arsch mit dem vorderrad ist ganz geil
macht ja auch mal morgens oft vorm
schulweg denn erstmal vorderreifen
männer spritzen acom das ist jetzt echt
das ist jetzt nicht mehr human was hier
gerade abgeht tschuldigung die pfeiler
sind dem weg die in deinen arsch sind
eltern felder wohl jetzt link ach ja
aber ich glaube ich weiß wie es geht
ich glaube wir müssten hier auf jeden
fall erstmal runter ja genau so muss das
sein muss mein kind da er kaum geschafft
hast ja gut ich blute nach frank moment
wartet das kommt das blut an gut wieder
so ein brutales level moment ich glaube
auch herr trainer a way to be an
adventure the view wenn er gar den
erotischen momente ich glaube die
verkehrte wird genau hier aktiv yao
einer von vier erwarten wir sind doch
nur einer von vielen moment ich als mal
eben vor so fahre ich immer runter war
sehr gut okay das habe ich schon mal
geschafft nein der helm ist kaputt das
können wir schaffen oder katy können wir
schaffen
ich weiß es nicht dass unser kind hatten
us ist per sagen wir mal nabelschnur mit
dem rücken von unserem vater verbunden
dem fahrer können wir mit james nennen
james potter und das kind da ist ein
harry potter so komm lass mich immer
rüber fahren das wäre echt extrem geil
von dir ja muss jetzt noch gar nicht so
notgeil darum drücken vor okay okay weil
es nicht so gutachter schüler tot ist
natürlich dann toll wenn unsere
einzelteile weiter ich verstehe es nicht
wenn ich zehn gedrückt halte 8 darf das
nicht gedrückt halten ich muss einfach
nur einmal zu drücken aber gut das
wusste ich nicht okay ich probier das
mal weiter papaya es ist natürlich dann
total toll wenn man dann erstmal dingen
zu eine fresse bekommt aber wir schaffen
das wir schaffen das für uns erkennt
nein nein
ok james moment es geschafft
ich will dir ne runde und ich blute aus
meinem oberschenkel halt die fresse du
sparst du hast gar kein bein mehr
ok weiter geht's heiko kraft
jetzt ist level ja und ich schaffe das
nicht aber zu meiner entschuldigung muss
ich sagen explosionen
was ist eine kraft hat auf den kopf
schnell der kann einfach mal so viele
menschen auf einmal tragen schon krass
jetzt lasst mich immer auf vorbei
es ist so geil das kind mit dem kopf
geht immer teilweise durch einen dingens
dadurch tischen sitzen wir fahren ein
kleines stück zurück und lassen die da
erst mal machen diese ganzen gedärmen
richtig geil finde ich das und fuß auch
cool
der fuß hindert uns daran dass wir daher
könne man das doch richtig pervers oh
mein gott wie der sich habe angetönt
fühlen muss entweder die ganze mit dem
reifen okay ich glaube da führt das
nicht mehr mit seinen paar körperteilen
moment ich fahr mal wieder stück zurück
ja wir müssen sich doch irgendwie
herkommt waren auf jeden fall eindeutig
zu viele tode macht mir nicht levels wo
ich ganz viele menschen umbringen man
das doch nicht gut was ich probier's mal
mit einer rolle ja sehr gut nicht so gut
nahe kommen das level ist jetzt nicht so
toll ich begibt einmal zwei sterne weil
da komm ich will nicht so ernst für mich
gemacht meine erste map blablabla alles
eure ersten maps dass er unglaublich
übrigens habe ich gerade meine dinge
wieder ausgeblendet hier meine maus
damit ihr die nicht die ganze zeit seht
pussy weg das level habe ich aus
langeweile moment gemacht ist nichts
besonderes bitte bewährtes wie es wie
sie es wollen
ok cool ich hoffe mal wir schaffen das
nicht aber relativ einfach außerhalb ist
ja noch kein mal normal so eine kleine
info wenn er ein level macht und ich
bisher noch fast gar nichts gedrückt
habe aus erhalten nach vorne fahren
dann solltet ihr das nicht so gestalten
dass ich direkt auf die fresse bekommen
und total verrückt sofort auch pate
komme aber wir schaffen das jetzt dass
das ist gewählt tut mir leid aber ein
stern you must be logged in ganz oben
steht zwar contractor eingeloggt aber
naja von crafter zweimal zweites level
es wird ja immer besser superwoman aber
wir brauchen ihre hilfe der supermarkt
wird soeben der fall in etwa das
vergessen machen uhr kann man da nicht
lesen
wer fallend fliegen sie sofort los
verstanden wir fliegen
ich warte mal wir können wir irgendwie
wir können nicht fliegen auf hat jetzt
habe ich losgelassen
ja wir schaffen da als ich liebe diese
hatte mit ihrem fürsten also den
würstchen in ihrem korb also nicht in
ihrem säcke korb sondern in ihrem korb
dann zum tragen
und das wäre jetzt gerade nicht so gut
moment also wenn das wirklich die die
leute die mir bisher level gemacht haben
die finde ich bisher nicht ganz so toll
natürlich echt cool von euch dass er mir
die ganze zeit level macht und so aber
die sollten dann auch funktionieren auch
da hätte es fast geschafft
ich glaube ich muss am anfang einfach
ein bisschen hüpfen mich ein paar mal
training mal ihren backspin noch mal in
front spin kommen wir es schaffen und
wir es geschafft und der wagen fährt und
er rollt und rollt und der wagen kommt
du schaffst das sagen komm ich blutete
sagen wagen nein nein bleibt da vorne
bleibt da vorne wir machen hier nicht
wir machen ja ok
jetzt habe ich aufgehört zu spritzen
bluten auch man so weiter geht es
verstanden neue kommen die cola die cola
bist du brauchst koffein sitzt gemütlich
weiter leben und wir haben jetzt voll
viele backspin und so haben es geschafft
wo der superman schreitet total fünf
sterne finde ich wirklich dass er will
kann ich aber nicht bewerten das sind
wird aber du guckst du das video jahre
gerade wahrscheinlich an um einen kanal
das war auch wird sich letztens bei
youtube dieser bug oder 30 do you have
lower youtube-channel ich zurück was ja
bei hemden willkommen zu beim ersten
level games spieler geht auf seinen
kanal wenn das level gut ist ich auf
jeden fall anders aus
oh mein gott ich glaube damit das
falsche fahrzeug gewählt oder moment ja
gut
achso übrigens ihr könnt mich jetzt alle
bei steam enden
ich habe mein linker also ich nehme
jetzt übrigens alle einladungen an
wollte ich nur sagen kommen er hängt
sich selber wir schaffen das wie jener
sagen würde wir schaffen das jorge okay
ich habe meinen link irgendwann mal bei
twitter gepostet von meinem profil aber
eigentlich wenn ihre konkrete eingibt
solltet ihr mich finden
also an alle die mich da irgendwie schon
mal annehmen wollten ich nehme euch die
mich da enden wollten ich nehme euch da
auch jetzt an und allerdings aber nur
wenige spiele schenken ein coach so
einfach bisher der fall der hat mir
wirklich ein spiel geschenkt ohne dass
sie es irgendwie wollte und das spiel
das kannte ich gar nicht hat mir dazu
ein paar videos angeguckt von zombie und
so weiter
bombay solltet euch merken genommen
jedenfalls so als sei hier schon
zurückkehrt ist unglaublich jedenfalls
hat er mir gesagt man jetzt machen wir
hier ahmadinedschad nach einkommen da
hab ich jetzt keine lust drauf tut mir
leid aber wenn man ganz viele genug
level von crafter das glied hey leute
luca eine map von mir für alle leute
lukas für alle lukas dieser welt ach so
ich dachte schon du schreibst du damit
klar dass es mord schreibt michael ca
so wie luca toni oder dass toni soll
nicht dem neuartigen sein bzw ausgrenzt
und sein hinter beziehungsweise
kommenden punkt mega get free cash flow
hier muss man respekt habe ich doch
ist das geil boah krass war ich habe
keinen bock mehr das durchzulesen
wo ist das geil geil wie krass und da
drin ist glaub ich sogar noch einen typ
mayo have to be very careful wenn er
meint die die schneider ein pfeil umher
die hat mich sogar festgehalten moment
war der weg schaffen das aber liegt mir
einfach immer so auf eine ach da war typ
drin moment erschaffen war so einfach
ganz ganz schnell
so kommt es auf reisende dritter wir
brauchen jetzt so indiana jones musik
[Musik]
oder videos angeht ich weiß ich habe den
film ich geguckt 1 1
wir wurden ausgeschieden von einem penis
ab geht's
einfach ganz ganz schnell dann schaffen
wir das ich weiß nicht was diese space
drücken herz genau bringt nein nein du
sollst mir nicht antun
genau das möchte ich komme ich mal eben
einen versucht das level an sich ist
extrem geil probiert es mal so ich bin
mit dieser allgemeinen happy besteuerung
kommen die tante mit natürlich cool kann
das im fußball mit der spielen wo alba
krass kraska swu bono sting dildo geiles
level man aber echt respekt an der ich
so eine idee aber ich mache ich mache
das nicht
hey contra ich hab ja publikum ich habe
ja einen ruf zu verlieren wissen
ich hatte den ruf mein gott man nun
schreien konnte hofft dass mein erstes
level agiert die schnauze voll von
ersten levels so nehmen wir wieder
diesen typen ja ja ja ich weiß das ist
dein erstes level ist heiko kreft aber
mein letztes level direkt beine
gebrochen
so kann man sich nicht irgendwie
ausbremsen in der luft aber gut wir
haben es geschafft
sehr schön rostock stimmung auch nein
ich konnte mein ich könnte mein
unternehmen das war es auch schon mit
meinem level ich hoffe natürlich jetzt
hat er gefallen blablabla ich kann ja
ähnlich bewerten war cool konnte hatte
boll das ist eine kreisförmige und
drehende achterbahn in der mitte ist
eine münze die duh einsammeln muss danke
dass du mein level bei dehner in deinem
let's play gespielt hast rob stringer
kein ding wo mein gott ich bin hier
schon wieder im dingens das müsste jetzt
ungefähr dem moment ich noch mal eben so
jetzt müsst ihr das ungefähr wieder
passen hat war das jetzt ja ich mal kurz
neustadt
[Musik]
ältermann allem an was los man wo sind
dann beide da ist die münze doch geil
geschafft neun minuten 96 bin bringt 96
geboren von rost wurst cooles level
coole idee ist okay wir nehmen wir
wieder hier unsere praxis ja ja sehr gut
das ist meine erste map plötzlicher tod
ja fast sage ich so mein gott ist man
sieht das ist dein erstes level ist
kommt eine schauen wir noch mehr
bewerber bleibt mir jetzt gar nicht
alles durch ich möchte einfach nur mal
kurz bei diesen tricks wurden keine
menschen verletzt so mark i o mein gott
eine fette frau kommen die können wir
auch gerne mal verletzen
euro mit einem fahrrad hüpfen kann man
nicht glaube ich komm komm komm du
schaffst das vollgas
so kommen schnell weiter hier ist sofort
fällig du hast so fortgeschafft man
joggen durch joggen bei der sohn peter
nicht peter james starb james nein ich
werde bestimmt nicht sterben so und hier
runter ich muss mich beeilen
achtung okay das war's dann wohl
hauptsache er blutet noch schön und
mainka kolster liegt an der höheren
zweck so dass mal wieder mit einer folge
happy wales macht mir levels die schon
gesagt und dann sehen wir uns in der
nächsten folge vielleicht so in einer
woche oder so wieder ciao